-House Republicans voted
in large numbers
against a bill that would
provide emergency funding
to address the nationwide
shortage of baby formula,
while a smaller number
of Republicans
voted against a second bill,
that would make it easier
for poor families
to buy formula.
Instead, Republicans would much
rather exploit the crisis
to rail against immigration.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
In case you have any doubt
at all that reality is,
in fact, a simulation
and we're all just test subjects
in some giant computer game,
being jerked around
for the entertainment
of our celestial overlords,
[ Laughter ]
here's an extremely
and shockingly real clip
of former
President George W. Bush
giving a speech yesterday
where he discussed
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
and accidentally confessed
to being a war criminal.
[ Laughter ]
-Russian elections are rigged.
Political opponents
are imprisoned
or otherwise eliminated
from participating
in the electoral process.
The result is an absence
of checks and balances in Russia
and the decision of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified
and brutal invasion of Iraq.
I mean, of Ukraine.
[ Chuckle ]
[ Laughter ]
Iraq, too.
Anyway.
[ Laughter ]
Seventy-five.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know,
when I started this show,
I poured exactly
one shot of whiskey
and left it in the drawer
of my desk for an emergency
and, throughout the entirety
of the Trump presidency,
I resisted using it,
but you know what? [Bleep] it.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
I really am certain that clip
was designed in a lab
to melt the brains of anyone
who was alive in 2003.
Back then, if you had called
the invasion of Iraq
brutal and unjustified,
the Bush administration
and Fox News
would've spent an entire week
calling you a traitor
and, anytime you went
to the airport,
the TSA would've given you
the full cavity search.
[ Laughter ]
[ Southern accent ]
Well, well, well, Mr. Meyers,
if it isn't 3.5 ounces
of toothpaste.
Squat and cough, joke boy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Remember, this was a time
in our history
that was so hysterical
and intolerant of dissent
that people started calling
French fries, freedom fries,
because France opposed the war,
[ Laughter ]
which was both petty
and pointless,
especially because we only
did it for French fries.
We didn't change French kissing
or French doors
or Mr. French and we didn't all
pretend that Larry Bird was
from Freedom Lick, Indiana.
[ Laughter ]
You know, what people don't
remember is that, to retaliate,
French people started calling
American cheese disgusting
100 years ago.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There is a direct line
from Bush to the modern GOP.
The Trump Republican Party
is the natural evolution
of the Bush Republican Party,
which was lawless
and authoritarian
and used culture war hysteria
to stir up resentments
and scare voters, the same way
the modern Republican Party
does now.
They've just switched
to different topics.
Back then, Bush wanted
to amend the Constitution
to ban gay marriage.
Now, Republicans want
to take baby formula
away from migrant children
in government custody.
-Our border children,
the illegal
immigrant children,
are getting formula.
-American families,
there's a shortage,
but if you're a migrant,
don't worry
because Uncle Sam
has a stash of that.
-These are not people
that respected our borders,
our laws,
and our sovereignty.
Why wouldn't all the pallets go
to American families, first?
-Apparently, there's no shortage
of baby formula
for illegal aliens.
Why are we feeding illegal
babies ahead of American babies?
-Illegal babies?
[ Laughter ]
Are you out of your
[bleep] mind?
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
I think I'm finally going
to drink that whiskey shot.
Oh, right!
[ Laughter and applause ]
I already had it today!
I made it almost 1,300 shows
and then I need it twice
in one "Look."
Look,
[ Laughter ]
as a rule, if you ever find
yourself uttering the words,
"Why are we feeding
illegal babies?",
or even just the words
"illegal babies,"
that's when you need to go in
for a CAT scan,
to see if the doctors
can find your soul.
[ Laughter ]
"No, we're -- we're looking
and it's just
a giant, blank void
where the soul should be."
[ Laughter ]
Also, again, think about how
insane and immoral
the phrase "illegal babies" is.
Babies can't be illegal.
They can't commit crimes.
You've never seen a gang
of babies on motorcycles
[ Laughter ]
holding up liquor stores.
And, even if you did,
it'd be cute as [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
I mean, my God,
these are babies!
By the way,
in the government's custody.
It would be, to put it mildly,
immoral, abomination,
and crime against humanity not
to feed them.
And, on top of being
ghoulish and horrific,
it wouldn't even solve anything.
-First of all, how many babies
are there at the border?
A few hundred, maybe a thousand?
Government doesn't release
the exact number.
It's somewhere in that ballpark.
In the United States, there are
about 3.7 million babies, okay?
So, clearly, the border babies
hogging all that formula
is not the problem here.
[ Laughter ]
-This assumes, of course,
that the doofuses
over at Fox News
are capable of doing math.
Have you ever really looked
in Brian Kilmeade's eyes?
There is nothing there.
[ Laughter ]
Sometimes I think he might
just be a nanny cam they set up
to see if Steve Doocy
is stealing
other people's lunch
from the staff fridge.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you no doubt heard
about the nationwide
baby formula shortage,
which is a very real
and horrifying crisis
affecting millions of families,
that needs immediate action.
There are several
contributing factors,
including a recall in February
by one of the nation's
largest manufacturers,
which shuttered a plant
in Michigan;
and supply chain disruptions
stemming
from the COVID pandemic.
It's also been difficult
to supplement supply
with formula imported
from Canada,
thanks, in part, to onerous
trade restrictions imposed
by the Trump administration.
-Trade experts say
the renegotiated NAFTA deal
under the Trump administration
made it nearly impossible
for Canada to export formula
to the U.S.
-During the Trump
administration,
when they renegotiated NAFTA
and they made the USMCA,
guess what they did?
Made it harder for Canada,
made it more expensive
for Canada
to import baby formula here.
-I mean, of course, Trump is,
somehow, involved in this.
Finding his fingerprints
on a screw-up, these days,
is like finding Waldo
in a book called...
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, that reminds me, Seth.
-Reminds you of what, Wally?
-I have a new kid's book
coming out called...
It's pictures of me
in the studio
and kids try to find me.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but aren't you always
in the same place,
holding cards behind the camera?
[ Laughter ]
-Tha--
Thanks for ruining
my book, Seth.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah, I --
-Whoo!
-Apologies, everyone.
The new restrictions
on formula imports from Canada
were implemented as part
of a renegotiated trade deal
called the USMCA.
Trump even branded it
and came up with a very dumb way
of getting people
to remember the name.
-USMCA, right?
Like
♪ YMCA ♪
[ Laughter ]
If you have a problem
remembering it,
just think of the song
"Y.M.C.A."
We love that song.
USMCA.
-[ As Trump ]
Just think of the YMCA
and, of course,
the Village People.
Think of the cop, the cowboy,
and, of course,
the leather daddy.
[ Laughter ]
Leather comes from cows,
cows produce milk,
and dairy imports are regulated
by the
♪ USMCA ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
It rolls off the tongue.
It's very natural
when you do it.
[ Laughter ]
So there are lots of reasons
for the formula shortage
and those problems
have been magnified by the fact
that the formula market
is largely controlled
by a small handful
of corporate monopolies.
Yeah, because you can't have
a small group of companies
all depending
on the same sources
for the same ingredients,
otherwise, crises like these
will be inevitable.
It's like if the only place
you could go
to get yourself clean,
have a good meal,
and...do whatever you feel
was the
-♪ YMCA ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
Does make it easier to remember.
[ Laughter ]
So...
Now, obviously, obviously, it is
on the Biden administration
and Congress
to fix the crisis immediately.
Biden announced
that he's invoking
the Defense Production Act
to produce more formula,
the FDA reached a deal
to open the shuttered plant,
and the House passed
an emergency funding bill
to address the crisis.
And yet, you'll never guess
who voted
against the emergency
funding bill.
Wait, sorry,
of course you can guess.
Almost every Republican.
-We'll start with a bill
that would send $28 million
to the Food and Drug
Administration
to help boost formula supply
and prevent future shortages.
Only 12 Republicans voted
for that measure.
House Democrats say the
emergency funding would be used
to increase the number
of FDA inspection staff,
help the agency stop
fraudulent baby formula
from entering
the U.S. marketplace,
and improve data collection
on the formula market.
-Only 12 Republicans voted
for a bill
to address the nationwide
formula shortage.
You know,
I'm starting to suspect
that maybe their criticisms
aren't exactly genuine.
I mean, when I saw
that 192 Republicans voted
against an emergency funding
bill for the FDA,
my first question was...
-♪ Y ♪
-Seriously.
[ Laughter ]
How can you be
against a bill like that?
It's like being the one guy
in the office who's
against free pizza for lunch.
"I'm sorry. What am I supposed
to do with the catfish
I just warmed up
in the microwave?"
[ Laughter ]
So, the House passed two bills.
One was an emergency funding
bill to address the shortage,
and almost every Republican
voted against it.
Another bill
would make it easier
for low-income families
to buy formula,
and that bill got much more
bipartisan support.
-The House also passed
another bill,
called the
Access to Baby Formula Act.
That final vote came down 414-9
and the bill would allow
more formula to be purchased
with money
from a federal program
that aids low-income women,
infants, and children.
-Supporting a bill like that
would seem like a no-brainer
and, yet, somehow, there were
still nine Republicans
who voted against it --
Andy Biggs, of Arizona...
Hearing that list of names
is like hearing the roll call
at a Legion of Doom meeting.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, who else voted
against this bill,
Skeletor? I'm just kidding.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just kidding.
Skeletor's not in Congress.
He's the president's lawyer.
[ Laughter, ohs, and applause ]
You guys.
Also, I got to say,
at least, with Skeletor,
you know what you're getting.
Dude's a giant,
maniacal skeleton in a hoodie.
He's upfront about being evil.
[ Laughter ]
He-Man's under no illusions
about who he's dealing with.
He-Man never started
an episode saying,
"Hey, maybe we should hear
Skeletor out."
[ Laughter ]
The nationwide formula shortage
is an urgent crisis
that requires immediate action
and, yet, for all their bluster,
Republicans have, once again,
made it clear
they have no interest
in actually governing
or helping solve the problem.
If you're feeling down,
they just want you
to pick yourself off the ground
because you're in a new town
[ Laughter ]
and head to the...
-USMCA.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.